Let's take a look at more
examples of using the model.
Remember that users are more
likely to download a free app
compared to a priced one.
There are numbers of ways to monetize
free apps by using in app billing.
>> Yeah, there's actually two
avenues that you can take.
There are objects that users
can purchase once, and
they're always able to access.
So, example, something like levels,
Telltale games, Angry Birds,
all allow users to unlock
new levels by paying for it.
There's also objects that users will
always need to keep purchasing, coins,
extra lives, boosters, gems, whatever.
Clash of Clans is an example of this.
>> In this model,
the goal is to gain trust.
We want to lower the entry barrier and
allow users to try us and fall in love.
After that, we can offer users who
are using the product to pay for it, and
they will be willing to do it with
a big smile if we are doing everything
correctly, because users will recognize
the value that we created for them.